in the last 27 months they've
deliberately admitted 2 million illegal
aliens into our country a population
larger than the state of Nebraska
and while the Border Patrol was
overwhelmed another 1.5 million known
gotaways have entered as well
that is an additional illegal population
larger than the entire state of Hawaii
the Trump policy slowed Encounters of
unaccompanied children to 33 000 the
lowest level in eight years
in the last fiscal year a record 152
000 came across that's almost a
five-fold increase
Biden had exactly the same tools
available to him as Trump
so it should be obvious this is a
deliberate policy that ignores not only
the welfare of Americans but that of the
migrant children as well
on a board trip last year I asked a CBP
officer how to stop the trafficking the
children into this country his answer
was immediate get them safely home
he said the cartels charged thousands of
dollars to traffic these children and
they don't give refunds the moment
children are returned home their
business will dry up
another border trip I was shocked to
learn that no effort is made to get
these children back to their homes and
very little effort is made vetting the
so-called sponsors of these children
very little interest is shown in
following up on their welfare once
they're abandoned to these so-called
sponsors
so what happens to them
the administration's response is
basically don't know don't care
but a recent New York Times
investigation sheds some light on this
question
after they get to the U.S many are
forced by their so-called sponsors into
dangerous jobs with fake identity
documents
earlier this year a Sanitation Company
employing over 100 illegal alien
children in jobs in slaughter houses and
meat packing plants in the midwest paid
one and a half million dollars of
several penalties after a federal court
found that these children were using
caustic chemicals to clean razor-sharp
saws and working overnight shifts
one of the great ironies of Bill titles
a trafficking victims protection
reauthorization act of 2008 makes this
possible while children from Mexico and
Canada are immediately sent safely home
all others are admitted that's a
tremendous incentive to send
unaccompanied children to the Border
in 2014 even the Obama Administration
recognized the danger and asked Congress
to provide it with quote additional
authority to exercise discretion in
processing the return and removal of
unaccompanied minor children from
non-contiguous countries like Guatemala
Honduras and El Salvador end quote
the house passed a bill to do just that
Senate Democrats blocked it
the Trump Administration was able to
staunch the flow with new and strict
requirements to ensure the safety of
these children once placed with a
sponsor as as well as title 42 expulsion
Authority
but in 2021 the Biden Administration
dismantled Trump error requirements to
vet sponsors and perform background
checks for individuals in the sponsor
household many of whom are involved in
smuggling the children in the first
place the Biden Administration stops
subjecting them to title 42.
we now know that the Administration has
simply lost track of over 85 000 of
these children
September 2022 axios reported that quote
roughly one in three follow-up calls
major released migrant kids to their
sponsors between January and may went
unanswered
don't know don't care
according to the New York Times the
cabinet secretary responsible for these
children javio Becerra likened the
sponsor placement process to an assembly
line that wasn't moving fast enough he
complained quote if Henry Ford had seen
this in his plant he would never become
rich and famous
this is not the way you do an assembly
line
last week this committee approved a bill
that would help stop this tragedy by
returning these children safely home as
we already do for children coming from
Mexico or Canada no Democrats supported
our bill
I'm hopeful that after hearing the
testimony of our Witnesses our
colleagues will rethink their opposition
to this long overdue reform
and although we're focusing today on
Young and vulnerable children we should
note that a large majority of so-called
unaccompanied children or late teenagers
or young men claiming to be minors but
that's the subject for another day I'm
now pleased to recognize the ranking
member for five minutes
thank you Mr chairman since this is the
first immigration subcommittee hearing
of the 118th Congress I just want to
start by congratulating you on becoming
chairman and also seeing how honored I
am to serve as ranking member as the
first South Asian American woman elected
to the house I came to this country by
myself at the age of 16. it took me 17
years on an alphabet soup of visas to
actually become a U.S citizen and prior
to coming to Congress I devoted a decade
and a half to working on the issue of
fair and Humane immigration policy so
this is an issue that's both personal
and Collective for me and I'm very proud
to be the first immigrant to serve as
either ranking or chair of the
subcommittee looking forward to working
with you and being in a position to help
shape the debate of reforming our
immigration system around the values of
dignity humanity and respect I also want
to sincerely thank representative
zoloftgren who has for the last 15 years
either chaired or been the ranking
member of the immigration subcommittee
she is a stellar champion for working
and Humane immigration system and I know
she's going to continue to be an
invaluable resource for this committee
and for our whole Congress now to the
work of the hearing unfortunately
between the hearings that we have held
and the cruel extreme and unworkable
immigration legislation that was marked
up last week this majority is once again
showing that they are not serious about
finding real solutions to fix our
complex immigration system
this hearing is ostensibly about showing
that the majority cares about the
exploitation of children but just last
week the same majority passed
legislation out of this committee that
would actually gut protections for
unaccompanied children that bill passed
out of committee with not a single
Democratic vote and even Republican
colleagues decrying the bill as extreme
Un-American and not ready for prime time
specifically that bill would allow
unaccompanied children to languish in
Border Patrol facilities for up to a
month it would force children to appear
within two weeks before an immigration
judge with no access to an attorney and
it would send children back to their
home countries where they are at high
risk for exploitation and abuse
the bill would decimate the bipartisan
trafficking victims protection
reauthorization act which Congress
passed on a sweeping bipartisan basis
and established the U.S government's
Central framework for keeping on
unaccompanied children out of the hands
of trafficking Democrats want to protect
children not make it even more difficult
for them to be safe and we've got more
work to do real serious work to make
that happen I was heartbroken reading
the New York Times articles about young
children who were being taken advantage
of by unscrupulous sponsors and
employers and the potential warning
signs that were missed this increase in
child labor is actually a trend that has
been steadily On The Rise especially
since 2018 under the former president
and it's completely unacceptable that's
why I was very pleased to see that the
office of refugee resettlement has
announced an audit of their sponsor
vetting process and I look forward to
seeing the results of that audit
I was also encouraged by the Department
of Labor and Health and Human Services
recent announcement of a variety of new
efforts to combat exploitative child
labor including a new interagency task
force to improve coordination and
information sharing among agencies
at the same time we know that the office
of refugee resettlement and the
administration overall need more
resources to do more to ensure the
safety of kids and we in Congress have a
responsibility to provide sufficient
funding to those agencies to do this
critical work that includes funding to
increase post-release services for
children after they're placed with a
sponsor as well as increased appointment
of counsel Improvement in both of these
areas will help help protect children
from mistreatment exploitation and
trafficking the Department of Labor also
needs to be more aggressive in going
after these unscrupulous employers to
the fullest extent of the law many of
these employers by the way were using
e-verify which just goes to show how
ineffective that system is which was in
the majority's bill last week and they
should be held accountable for hiring
kids and subjecting them and all workers
to harsh conditions
every policy is about real human beings
and so I just want to close with a
success story of an unaccompanied child
who came to the United States a few
years ago fifteen-year-old Alejandra
fled The Gangs of El Salvador with her
ten-year-old brother and sought safety
here in the United States here they
reunited with their mother after being
separated for 10 years
when she arrived in the United States
Alejandra did not speak English she had
problems understanding her teachers and
she debated dropping out of school but
she Drew inspiration from her mother and
from the support network around her
including the legal representation that
she was fortunate to obtain and she
persevered she ended up graduating high
school as the salutatorian of her class
and going to George Washington
University on a full ride where she
majored in Biology there are so many
alejandras out there waiting for
Congress to help keep them safe and help
them succeed by passing Humane
immigration laws that's what we should
be focused on today I look forward to
hearing from our Witnesses today the
protection of children from exploitation
abuse and trafficking should be a
bipartisan issue I hope my colleagues
approach it that way today I yield back
thank you we have with us the ranking
member of the House Judiciary Committee
Mr Nadler is recognized for five minutes
from opening statement and thank the
gentleman Mr chairman today's hearing
would have been more appropriate to
conduct last week before the Republican
majority marked up its extreme
enforcement-only immigration legislation
the majority supposed concern for the
exploited children that are the subject
of today's hearing is hard to reconcile
with a bill that would render
unaccompanied children more vulnerable
to exploitation and abuse
that legislation would eliminate the
right of many unaccompanied children at
the border to seek protection in
Immigration Court from Human Trafficking
and other dangers and to receive robust
screenings by child welfare experts for
evidence of mistreatment
that legislation would leave these
unaccompanied children with the right
merely to cursory screenings by law
enforcement Personnel lacking child
welfare expertise
screenings that would largely fail to
identify signs of trafficking and
exploitation
this would lead to the summary return of
too many children with valid protection
claims to the same dangers they fled
even more alarmingly Republicans bill
would subject unaccompanied children to
detention in jail like Customs and
Border Protection facilities for up to
30 days 10 times longer than what is
permitted under current law
unaccompanied children who would undergo
their first integration court hearing
within 14 days of their border screening
this would leave them with almost no
time to obtain counsel to understand
their legal options or in many cases to
comprehend what a court hearing even is
much less to demonstrate their
eligibility for legal protection and
trafficking and other mistreatment
and as if and as if that's not bad
enough their bill would prohibit Health
and Human Services from funding Council
for unaccompanied children stripping
thousands of children of the lawyers
they depend on to protect them from
exploitation and other harm
as we pointed out last week many of the
components of the bill were not
discussed in a hearing is Congress
that makes sense given that we are four
months in this is the first hearing the
immigration subcommittee has held
too bad because if this subcommittee had
met earlier we could have also discussed
the flaws of the e-verify system
some of the companies that employed and
exploited the children or the subject of
recent reporting use the e-verify system
to ensure that their employees are
eligible to work
it clearly did not work correctly or it
was abused it would have been helpful
before we marked up legislation that
mandated Nationwide e-verify to learn
about these issues
we could have discussed how HR 2640
contains minus protections for
authorized workers what are the signs no
penalties to employers who violate these
protections under e-verify rendering
these Provisions practically meaningless
yes I think the committee would have
learned a lot if it had actually held a
hearing on this issue before marking up
that cruel and extreme piece of
legislation
last week's markup we heard a lot from
our Republican colleagues about the
so-called missing 85 000 kids as
reported by the New York Times
let's be clear that headline was
misleading when such allegations were
made against the office of refugee
resettlement under the previous
administration and it is misleading
today we will discuss that issue in
Greater detail during the hearing
however the New York Times reporting of
children unlawfully working in Factory
slaughterhouses and other dangerous jobs
is very concerning Orr and the
Department of Labor have taken some
positive steps forward to address these
issues or make no mistake more must be
done
that will take significant resources
devoted to both agencies agencies that
would likely see Draconian Cuts if the
Republicans are successful in their
effort hold our economy Hostage to their
extreme debt reduction demands while
they threaten the catastrophic default
on a nation's credit
as we consider Federal efforts to
address the exploitation of children
it is not helpful that in multiple
Republican legislatures across the
country
states are loosening their child labor
laws to allow children to lawfully work
in some of these dangerous occupations
the fact that Republicans are actively
making it easier for young teenagers to
work in assembly line plans flutter
houses and night shifts in States like
Iowa and Arkansas is appalling and it
only encourages the exploitation of
these vulnerable children
it is hard to take seriously the party
that boasts of its concerns for
exploited children are simultaneously
stripping vital protections from
unaccompanied children promoting
policies that would create the
conditions for these children to be
exploited and then starving agencies of
the resources necessary to protect them
from exploitation
Republicans want to engage in a serious
effort to protect children Democrats
stand ready to work with you I look
forward to hearing from the witnesses
today and yield back the balance of my
time
thank you and now we're very honored to
have four Witnesses with us today Ms
Tara Lee wrote us is a federal employee
with the Council of the inspectors
general for integrity and efficiency
she's speaking to us today in her
personal capacity as a whistleblower
witnessed and reported the harm and
danger to unaccompanied alien children
while working as a volunteer with the
office of refugee resettlement in the
Department of Health and Human Services
she worked at the Pomona emergency
intake site in California that housed
and processed thousands of unaccompanied
Alien Children arriving at the Southwest
border in 2021. nashina Rodriguez is the
founder and president of the alliance
for a safe Texas
mother and former teacher who founded
the alliance for a safe Texas during the
current border crisis as part of her
work she's interviewed many women and
children who have crossed our Southwest
border as testified before the Texas
state legislature regarding the impacts
of the Border
Miss Jessica Vaughn is the director of
policy studies for the center for
immigration studies the Washington D.C
based Research Institute that examines
the impact of immigration on American
society her area of expertise is
immigration policy and operations are
covering topics such as unaccompanied
Alien Children Visa programs immigration
benefits and immigration enforcement
uh and finally Mr Robert Kerry served as
the Director of the office of refugee
resettlement within the U.S Department
of Health and Human Services Under the
Obama Administration prior to his
service at Orr he served as vice
president of resettlement and migration
policy at the International Rescue
committee Mr Perry has served as a chair
of the refugee Council of the United
States of America I want to welcome all
of our Witnesses and thank you for
appearing we'll Begin by swearing you in
which you will please rise and raise
your right hand
do you swear or a firm under penalty of
perjury that the testimony you were
about to give is true and correct to the
best of your knowledge information and
beliefs will help you God
great thank you very much so let the
record reflect with the witnesses have
answered in the affirmative
um please know that you're written
testimony will be entered in the record
in its entirety accordingly we'd ask
that you summarize your testimony in
five minutes
Mr Perry I want to begin with you
thank you Mr chairman ranking member and
members of the subcommittee for the
opportunity to appear before you today I
am Bob Carey I was the director of the
office of refugee resettlement Orr in
the Department of Health and Human
Services from March of 2015 through
January of 2017.
or are in addition to its work on behalf
of refugees asylees and other vulnerable
populations is responsible for the care
and maintenance of unaccompanied
children while they are in U.S
government custody and their placement
review ice-based sponsors while they go
through their immigration proceedings
the placement process includes vetting
of sponsors to verify their relationship
to the child and the suitability of the
placement
the overwhelming majority of sponsors
are immediate or close family members
the vetting process is rigorous and is
derived from a range of sources
including records obtained from the
countries of origin through their U.S
consulates and documentation provided by
U.S based sponsors
there are however limitations on Orr's
capacity to review information obtained
both prior to and after the release of
children
the office and the agency in what it is
which it is housed are not investigative
or law enforcement bodies
many of the children profiled in recent
coverage were taken into custody at our
Southern border they faced physical and
sexual violence human trafficking
forced gang recruitment and the very
real possibility of death in their home
countries and in flight
rather than fall prey to these forces
they fled often to join family in the
U.S
a remote remained vulnerable after even
after arriving
it has been alleged that approximately
85 000 children have been lost by Orr
in fact most of these children were
released to the care of a parent or
close relative
I believe that failure to respond to a
follow-up phone call from an unknown
phone number does not constitute being
lost
recent investigations have documented
the use of child labor in workplaces in
the U.S including among others
unaccompanied children admitted to the
U.S pending adjudication of their Asylum
claims
there are multiple explanations for this
inadequate funding and enforcement of
existing child protection and labor laws
outdated statutes that allow large
corporations to skirt workplace
responsibility by using intermediaries
partisan politics designed to divide and
demonize foreign-born people
and insufficient coordination among
government agencies among others
since I left Orr Congress has repeatedly
directed Orr to enhance protections for
children
in response Orr has dramatically
increased the number of children who
receive post-release services
implemented post-release Social Services
often referred to as PRS are essential
to ensuring the safety stability and
transition to permanency of
unaccompanied Children released from
government cost custody to sponsors in
the United States
I am pleased to see oro's progress as I
believe these vital services are vital
tools to ensure a child's safety while
they go through Immigration Court
processes
further Orr has stated that it plans to
provide legal representation
representation to 100 percent of
unaccompanied children by the end of
fiscal year 27 which is an essential
objective
no less crucial of for protecting
children is access to an attorney
currently many if not most unaccompanied
children lack an attorney
TV pra requires that to the maximum
extent practical
HHS ensure legal counsel for
unaccompanied children
to represent them in legal proceedings
or matters and protect them from
mistreatment exploitation and
trafficking
this includes mistreatment and
exploitation in the workplace
providing unaccompanied children with
attorneys for the duration of their case
is one of the best ways to intervene
early when children are working in
illegal and dangerous conditions and
thus to protect them from abuse
attorneys also help evaluate children's
eligibility for legal protections and
Supportive Services specifically
designed for survivors of trafficking
severe crimes and abuse
this includes work authorization where
eligible which helps older teenagers
access safe lawful and appropriate
employment and serves as a bulwark
against dangerous working conditions
wage theft and other labor abuses in the
unregulated workforce
let me conclude by reiterating that
unaccompanied children are by and large
children in need
when the exploitation of underage
unaccompanied children occurs it
requires multiple failures
the solutions require addressing all
five of these factors
accountability for those who exploit
children
accountability for those that profit
from child labor exploitation
expanded
and enhanced access to post-release
Services legal services and child
advocates
expanded legal Authority and resource to
to act affirmatively to investigate
possible child labor exploitation and to
provide protection to affected children
better communication across federal
federal agencies but also Orr can do a
better job I'm sorry to interrupt your
time expired about a minute ago thank
you
with questions thank you it says next
I'm pleased to recognize Ms Juan
foreign
thank you Mr chairman and ranking member
for having a hearing on this topic which
has been ignored for too long it's
disturbing and sad to hear the stories
of what these younger migrants go
through they are no less deserving of
personal safety and protection just
because of the circumstances under which
they arrived
so it's also infuriating though because
the dysfunction in the Orr placement
program has been known for a long time
for about 10 years since States and
local communities that have been dealing
with the influx started raising the
alarm
what is most infuriating is that even
with all the well-documented risks and
problems associated with the federal
government taking custody of minors and
adults claiming to be minors who are
smuggled in and then releasing them to
unvetted sponsors and then washing its
hands of responsibility for them even
knowing the risks
still the Biden Administration chose to
throw gasoline on that dumpster Fire by
actually expanding opportunities for the
illegal smuggling of minors into the
country and expanding opportunities for
these minors to be trafficked for cheap
labor commercial sex gangs and more
it was done by dismantling the
relatively effective policies enacted by
prior administrations that had tried not
only to improve the UIC placement system
and mitigate the risk of trafficking but
to decrease the flow of child migrants
under the Biden policies the annual
number of uacs referred to HHS custody
after Crossing illegally has tripled
from an average of forty thousand a year
to more than a hundred and twenty
thousand in each of the last two years
half of the six hundred thousand
unaccompanied minors who've been
released in the country since 2012 have
arrived on Biden's watch
not only did he relax border controls
and suppress immigration enforcement
inside the country when the numbers
predictably exploded his officials
responded by gutting what few meager
protections for child migrants still
existed as HHS secretary Becerra
revealed in this now notorious video
statement the goal was to release these
kids faster with fewer questions asked
to make it a more efficient assembly
line and this assembly line is staffed
by crony contractors spending billions
of taxpayer dollars on what is now a
pipeline for child labor trafficking
it is truly an urgent task for Congress
to address this problem there is no
question that the placement process for
uacs can be improved these improvements
should be informed by experts like those
here today who know the system by child
welfare agencies within the states and
communities where the migrants are
placed and by the federal immigration
and other law enforcement agencies who
understand the smuggling and trafficking
business
we need these improvements and we need
more oversight on HHS and its
contractors just last night I got a
message from an Insider voicing their
concern about how HHS lets its
contractors
operate the youth migrant shelters with
unlicensed and untrained staff who
apparently are utterly unqualified to be
in charge of these kids
we would never allow this to happen in a
school or any other juvenile setting
involving American Kids
but fixing the shelter and placement
system is not going to solve the problem
really based on my experience I see no
chance that the Federal Government Can
construct a system for processing
unaccompanied illegal alien minors that
is up to the task of handling the huge
number of kids
more than 120 000 last year who will
continue to come who will continue to be
put in the hands of criminal Smugglers
traffickers unscrupulous employers
abusive sponsors as long as they know
that they're going to be released into
the country once they get here
fundamental problem which Congress can
solve is with the law
first the loopholes in the tvpra must be
closed
allowing the government to swiftly
repatriate the miners to their homes if
they are not at risk which most are not
and Congress must direct and fund ice to
boost its anti-trafficking and its
worksite enforcement activities to go
after the illegal and exploitative
employment of the young migrants
it is also imperative to restore Isis
authority to arrest sponsors who it
finds have been involved in the
smuggling or trafficking or illegal
employment of these minors
which was taken away from them by the
Harris amendment that passed a couple of
years ago which I noted in my written
statement
Congress should use its Appropriations
authority to force HHS and DHS to have
meaningful coordination with state and
local governments and their child
welfare agencies and finally Congress
should reform other Provisions in the
law that entice minors to come illegally
such as the special immigrant juvenile
program which should be limited to
accommodate only those youth who have no
responsible parent or godrey aim to care
for them thank you
thank you very much for your testimony
and next we hear from Ms Rodriguez for
five minutes
good afternoon and thank you chairman
and members of the committee for giving
me this opportunity to present my
eyewitness testimony and express my
concerns regarding what is happening to
the children at the southern border
because of the current administration's
policies I am Sheena Rodriguez founder
and president of Alliance for safe Texas
as a U.S citizen mother and former
educator who deeply cares about our
country and the welfare of all children
I was compelled to see for myself what
was occurring at our Southern border I
have been to various parts of the Border
in Texas and Arizona nearly three dozen
times in under two years would I have
witnessed would and should discussed and
terrify every American
in April 2021 when Texas governor Greg
Abbott learned of allegations of abuse
of unaccompanied minors in a federal
facility in San Antonio he stated quote
the Biden Administration is presiding
over the abuse of children he also
called on the administration to shut
these facilities down instead the
Administration has only expanded them
without communicating with state and
local authorities local communities are
not told how long the miners will be
there or where they will go when they
are released and with no concern to the
local of impact to the local cities I am
requesting that Contra that Congress
launch a full investigation into the
federal agencies responsible for
approving these contracts these are just
a handful of many examples I have
encountered during one border trip to
the Del Rio area in December of 2021 the
group I was with encountered six men who
had illegally entered the U.S and were
hiding in the brush they surrounded our
vehicle believing that we were their
transport to smuggle them further into
the U.S when we spoke to them they said
that they had witnessed cartel
operatives murder children who were
traveling alone and could not pay the
smuggling fees one man claimed he
witnessed children being used and traded
as currency in another encounter in La
Jolla I met and spoke with a
ten-year-old Honduran girl who arrived
by herself carrying only a small piece
of paper with handwritten phone numbers
on it she stated the numbers were given
to her by a woman and an NGO along the
Route who told the young girl the
numbers were to her father who she said
that she would be staying with a man the
young girl claimed she had never met or
spoken to also in La Jolla I met a 14
year old girl reportedly abused by her
father and claimed that she was held for
11 days in and abused further similarly
she was told by a stranger that she
would be going to stay with her mother
who the teen claimed again she did not
know
I also met teenage boys between the ages
of 14 to 17 who claimed cartel
operatives often transported children
through Mexico and held them at the
bodegas where armed cartel members stood
guard many were told they were going to
stay with sponsors in America with
several claims again that the teens had
never met or personally communicated
with their supposed sponsors
since January 2021 there have been over
000 uacs encountered at the southern
border a majority of which have been
released into the U.S more than ten
thousand of which that have been
released in my respective area of North
Texas the current Administration has
admitted that they do not keep track of
the whereabouts when they are released
into the U.S with the use of taxpayer
dollars tens of thousands of children
are simply missing
how many of the missing children are in
my city or in yours this has forced the
state of Texas to take actions we never
should have had to take as a direct
result of the failed Federal policies
currently we have bipartisan support for
my state level legislative sponsored
letter calling for a state investigation
into the trafficking of unaccompanied
minors in Texas I am calling on Congress
to investigate the federal agencies
responsible for these minors to locate
these children and to act with urgency
to end the policy of releasing uacs in
the U.S with sponsors in non-family
members they do not know I am also
calling on Congress to require that all
alleged family members undergo a DNA
test the abuse of children is not a
political or partisan issue it is a
humanitarian and legal issue I am
calling on Congress to investigate the
actions of DHS secretary Alejandro
mayorkas HHS secretary Xavier Becerra
and Border Czar vice president Kamala
Harris and to identify by their role in
facilitating the abuse of children
through federal agencies and demand that
they be held accountable I agree with
Florida Governor Rhonda Sanchez who
describes what is happening as quote the
effectively the largest human smuggling
operation in American history we can no
longer turn a blind eye and pretend that
this isn't happening Congress has the
power to stop this which is why I'm
calling on you to do what is right
Americans and these children deserve no
less thank you
thank you for your testimony or our
final Witnesses Ms Rodas is recognized
for five minutes
good afternoon chairman McClintock
ranking member DePaul and distinguished
members of the committee
it is an honor to be here I thank you
for the invitation to share my testimony
my goal is to inspire action to
safeguard the lives of Migrant children
including the Staggering 85 000 that are
missing
today
children will work overnight shifts at
slaughterhouses factories restaurants to
pay their debts to Smugglers and
traffickers today children will be sold
for sex
today children will call a hotline to
report they are being abused neglected
and trafficked and we don't know if
they're going to get the help they need
for nearly a decade unaccompanied
children have been suffering in the
shadows and I have to confess I knew
nothing about their suffering until 2021
when I volunteered to help the Biden
Administration with the crisis at the
southern border as part of operation
Artemis I was deployed to the Pomona
Fairplex emergency intake site in
California to help HHS office of refugee
resettlement reunite children with
sponsors in the United States
I thought I was going to help these
children in loving homes instead I
discovered that children are being
trafficked through a sophisticated
Network that begins with recruiting in
Home Country smuggling to the U.S border
and ends when Orr delivers a child to a
sponsor some sponsors are criminals and
traffickers and members of transnational
criminal organizations some sponsors
view children as Commodities and assets
to be used for earning income this is
why we are witnessing an explosion of
Labor trafficking
now whether it's intentional or not
it could be argued that the United
States government has become the
middleman in a large scale
multi-billion dollar child trafficking
operation that is run by Bad actors
seeking to profit off of the lives of
children
as for me my interest is the safety of
the children I do not view this as a
political issue I view this as a
humanitarian issue I assure you my
motives are the highest and best I want
the children protected so I want to tell
you some of what I witnessed personally
at the Pomona Fairplex I saw vulnerable
indigenous children from Guatemala who
speak Mayan dialects and cannot speak
Spanish that means they cannot ask for
help in English they cannot help for ask
for help in Spanish
they become captives of their sponsors
I have sat with case managers as they
cried
to tell me the horror of what has
happened to children as they make the
journey to this country
I saw apartment buildings were 20 30 and
40 unaccompanied minors have been
released I saw sponsors trying to
simultaneously sponsor children from
multiple Orr sites at one time I saw
sponsors using multiple addresses to
abstain obtain sponsorships of children
and I saw numerous cases of children in
debt bondage
and the child knew they had to stay with
the sponsor until the debt was
realizing that we were not offering the
children the American dream but instead
putting them in modern day slavery with
Wicked overlords
was a terrible revelation
a terrible Revelation these children are
a captive victim population with no
access to law enforcement or knowledge
of their rights they are extorted abused
neglected and that is why I blew the
whistle in 2021
I witnessed firsthand the horrors of
child trafficking and exploitation my
life will never be the same after what I
saw but I have hope
because I'm counting on you
it's my hope that you'll take action to
end this crisis to safeguard the lives
of most of these vulnerable children
people have asked me you know what can
be done what would you suggest well
first I think hhs's number one priority
is oversight they must commit to
oversight transparency and
accountability if I could wave a magic
wand this I believe could be quickly
solved by experts in the IG community
there is a pandemic analytics Center of
Excellence or the pace as we call it I
believe if data analysts at the pace
could look at the data children could be
rescued criminals could be prosecuted if
the pace had access to this data it
shows where the children are and who has
them I think also we need to change the
culture of speed over safety speed is
the wrong performance measure when
dealing with children we need to revamp
the vetting process of sponsors and have
case managers who have investigative
backgrounds data analytics backgrounds
some certified fraud examiners and I
think we need to reimagine a system
where the sponsor is the accountable
party sponsors should be required to
report to Orr
and lastly
stop retaliating against whistleblowers
stop retaliating against the people who
are trying to tell the truth to save the
children
as it is written a wise man listens to a
vice while a fool continues in his folly
and HHS needs to be wise to care for his
children thank you very much your time's
expired well thank you for the
opportunity you're very welcome and
we'll get to the questions now under the
five-minute rule would begin Mr van Drew
of New Jersey
thank you very much Mr chairman I first
of all I want to thank you for
whistleblowing it's people like you and
all of you that when you come forward
and tell the truth those are big words
tell the truth you know what you want to
know and I'm going to be a little
different and I'm going to be a little
bit political because we have the other
side of the aisle saying that we're
hurtful we're cruel we're harsh we're
inhumane our bill is bad they were in
the majority when this was all done this
is their plan I've spoken to Mr mayorcus
numerous times more than once more than
twice more than three times and he has
told me that there's nothing wrong
everything is fine everything is good
our system is working and it's better
than ever the bottom line is we change
the system a number of years ago where
we opened our gates we opened our doors
but we don't have all the ability to
take care of everybody all the time and
that's the truth we only we have enough
problems in America that we can only
help legal immigrants and do things at a
certain Pace we just can't let the gates
be open and that is exactly what was
happening under this Administration is
exactly what they've done I don't want
to be partisan believe it or not I don't
like being partisan but I have to be in
this case because when you when Mr
mayorcus tells me nothing is wrong when
you see that adults are pretending to be
children in some cases as well and
taking advantage when you see little
babies that are just tossed aside when
you see children that are bought and
sold used for sex slavery and worse
multiple times I mean the stories are
horrific I know how you were sick and
you know what I don't want anybody from
the other if we want to find Solutions
we have Solutions and people have to
stay home or go back home and we need
legal immigration and we need a border a
border that really works a border that
is solid abort that doesn't allow this
to happen to children but you know what
the real goal here is to bring in as
many undocumented people and you talked
about speed and that's the way they're
doing it as they possibly can as fast as
they can to just bring them in so the
numbers go up double triple we see just
Millions upon millions of undocumented
illegal immigrants it doesn't do them
good it certainly doesn't do these
children good and that's what's cool
that's what's harsh that's what's
inhumane that's what's wrong and what's
going on and it has to be stopped we do
need a system and we do have to look at
HHS that should have been done in the
beginning two years ago when this all
started we weren't in control we didn't
have the ability to do it we we talked
about it we asked about it we pushed for
a change but we didn't have the ability
to do it so I don't want anybody and if
they they can do it but man you come to
me and say that it's my fault in the
minority at the time or that it was the
Republicans fault or that were mean bad
people that want to hurt no this is the
system that you all set up on the other
side of the aisle this is your system
this is what you did this is what you
made and of course it's not going to
work of course it's worse it is so much
better if children they're trying to
bring children that are undocumented
over let them go back to their home let
them go through a legal process I know
it takes time but it's the only way
that's going to work we're destroying
our country we're hurting little babies
we're destroying other countries in the
way that we're doing this and what we're
also doing is making a place for the
cartels in America I read somewhere
recently they said you know our latest
challenge is going to be it's going to
have to be like the military to go after
the cartels the cartels shouldn't even
be in America they shouldn't have the
ability to do this to these children
these children and their and their
families whatever are given false hope
and false aspirations and I'm tired of
it and I'm tired of being blamed for
something that somebody else made that
somebody else created that we didn't do
and Mr chairman I yield back
oh well I'm I'm sorry I'm going to
actually yield yes hey thanks thank the
general for yielding
um Mr Kerry during your tenure of about
two years
um there were 93 000 roughly 93 000
unaccompanied minors that that came to
HHR or excuse me Orr during your time is
that is that a fair number first
statement
you need to put the microphone on I
would have to check on those numbers
that's that's what the official website
indicates and um are you familiar that
since January 2021 there's been 356
thousands just under 357 000 uh
unaccompanied children that have come
across yes I'm aware of that thank you
everyone else back
thank you Mr chairman
I want to discuss the 85 000 so-called
lost children that we've heard so much
about in this committee Mr Kerry as you
testified the New York Times wrote a
detailed article with some very
concerning stories related to
unaccompanied children unlawfully
working in some very dangerous
conditions and I've said before that
these incidents are extremely upsetting
they need to be addressed the article
also discussed how the office of refugee
resettlement did not know the
whereabouts of those 85 000
unaccompanied children who have been
released to sponsors since the Biden
Administration began many outlets and
some of my colleagues have latched onto
this headline to claim that the Biden
Administration has quote lost 85 000
children and so I want to start with the
most important question because you ran
the office of refugee resettlement are
those children actually lost by the
federal government
no they are not
approximately 85 percent and during my
tenure 90 of those children were going
to parents or very close relatives
upwards of 70 I believe were going to
their parents
so uh it was the reunification of
families that was taking place now it is
true that some of those calls are not
answered however not answering a phone
call I do not believe constitutes losing
a child
um there are some very legitimate
reasons why those calls might not be
answered they are unknown numbers from
the US government uh they're not
recognized I think that understandably
people do not answer calls from unknown
numbers
they may be fearful of uh traffickers I
don't know other forces so
um in short I do not believe that it
constitutes being lost so when somebody
says lost what they're talking about is
that a phone call to verify and speak to
the child was not answered and then that
that gets constituted as quote lost so
if I remember correctly in 2018 the
previous administration was accused of
the same issue when headlines appear
stating that the Trump Administration
lost 1500 children in a three-month
period is that correct yes and those
claims were untrue as well
I believe those claims were in fact true
because the families were separated
um some children went at the time of
Entry they were separated and there were
databases that did not track where the
parents went and where the children went
so the situation was
um substantially different
and you're talking about a time when the
Trump Administration actually separated
thousands of children from their
families in fact I remember going and
visiting some of those parents in a
Federal Detention Center they had no
idea where their parents were in fact
the government had no idea what those
kids were can you discuss why the office
of refugee resettlement does not do more
in its follow-up I mean that is one of
the things that has been raised that I
think we all want to understand in your
opinion what more could the office of
refugee resettlement be doing well I
think it's important to understand what
the parameters are on the Orr office
operations the statutory Authority
granted to Orr extends only up to the
time of release
so Orr has no
authority to track or to investigate
it's not an investigatory body so it's
our law enforcement body so while
substantial resources are directed on
that area it lacks the expertise tools
staff and resources to conduct
investigatory
um
processes so you you mentioned in your
testimony that uh
Orr has no authority over children
working for example illegal child labor
is that correct or who who has
responsibility for that that would be
the Department of Labor I believe so
that is really not a function of Orr I
want to thank you Mr Carey because I
think this question of additional
post-release services and in fact even
some of the Republican Witnesses have
talked about this I think that's an area
that we believe is important to ensure
that there are in-person follow-ups to
ensure that there is appointment of
counsel that's something we we didn't
cover but that's only going to help
ensure that these kids stay safe and
that their claims are heard so I
appreciate your testimony it's important
that we get the facts out there that we
don't use the word lost in uh in in a in
a way that's not factual because really
what we're talking about is a phone call
was made and
um that that was not responded to that
phone call was not responded to for all
the reasons that you mentioned I thank
you and I yield back Mr chairman thank
you
Mr Biggs of Arizona thank you Mr
chairman I do think it's interesting
that the ranking member of the
subcommittee earlier today in the
previous hearing referred to the crisis
at the borders the so-called crisis just
like she referred to eighty five
thousand uh lost children as so-called
lost children I think that that gives
you the mindset
that you need to see
when I was down at La Jolla one time I
remember with CBP agent and I we go we
went to down there if you remember how
how it is in La Jolla you go and you can
watch people coming across the river and
they're coming up the road and there's a
sign that tells them where to go which
way to go because that's where CBP is
it's just myself and an agent it's night
time and we saw a group and they they
saw us we're 200 yards away there's 150
or so of them
they don't want to come because they're
not quite sure who we are so we yell at
them you know we're we're border patrol
come on up
so they come on up there was nobody over
the age of 18.
no one
we had kids who were three years old
coming across
who did who were they coming with a
coyote had brought them across the river
and said go go your own way we'll go
with this group of people
is that Humane Miss wrote us
Ms Rodriguez is that humane
absolutely not Ms Vaughn
Mr
no not at all there's policies that
entice people to come like that and
frankly if we're talking about
um relying on phone calls as so-called
monitoring of kids post placement
that's not I'm going to get into that
don't don't go there yet I'm going to
get into that
I've been in Yuma
and I have seen the evidence
of kids being reused
to create a family unit
same kid same kid over and over again
rent a kid
not humane
but we're told that
he's calling 85 000 children lost
that have been placed and by the way it
isn't we're it's not 90 going to parents
anymore
it's a third or less going to parents
in today's statistics and numbers
that
ranking member wants to get the facts
out those are the facts
now Ms Rodas you have said
that the US government is the middleman
and a multi-billion dollar
migrant child trafficking operation
what did you mean when you use the term
Middleman
are you microphone please
so the United States government is
receiving the children from the
Smugglers
at the border
and HHS is a 2.7 trillion dollar agency
and over the last two years has spent
approximately 10 billion dollars
so they are using that money to receive
those children and then
transport those children to the end user
and when you say end user we're not
talking necessarily even a blood
relative so I heard I heard Democrat
witness talk about vetting
can any of you talk about vetting I I
mean I could talk about vetting but I
want to hear from the witnesses tell us
about the vetting that you've observed
well in my personal capacity as the
deputy of the federal case management
team vetting I would like to say I with
Mr Kerry what he said is they are not an
investigative organization nor are they
law enforcement there was no one I was
shocked and I am stunned that there is
no one with law enforcement experience
overseeing where children are going you
have people applying for children who we
know are members of transnational
criminal organizations yet there's no
one with any and data analytics
background or anything like that
overseeing this operation it doesn't
really pass the common sense test when
we're pumping tens you know billions of
dollars into a program that's overseen
by people who simply are not qualified
to do the job when one individual can
sponsor 20 or 30 or 40 people and no
one's asking a question about it there's
something seriously wrong and flawed
with that program that's ultimately how
they found that one child in Yuma
because everybody was going to the same
place in Charleston South Carolina Ms
Vaughn you were going to expand on on on
the phone calls which I agree with you I
only have time to ask the question
what goes on in that phone call and um
and then I want to submit some stuff for
the record Mr chairman after she said
am I okay
a phone call is not sufficient to detect
um whether the child is in a safe
environment
a phone call is not enough to know if a
child is being abused the child is in a
forced labor trafficking situation that
is not acceptable monitoring and
shouldn't be considered monitoring at
all that is just a contractor going
through the motions of trying to see if
a child is there and frankly I think
almost all of these kids are actually
lost because the federal government is
taking no responsibility expired but uh
yes in advance consent requests yes Mr
chairman I have a letter that I wrote to
Orr the director of Orr in October in
her response in January of this year
admitting that they had lost contact
with more than 42 000 children
okay without objection
uh you know uh recognize Mr Nadler
thank you Mr chairman Mr Kerry I want to
discuss the vetting process that the
office of refugee resettlement
undertakes before it releases any
unaccompanied unaccompanied child to his
sponsor here are some of the news
organizations talk about this process
you think the children are just given to
anyone it's really much more extensive
than that can you discuss the assessment
that Orr does of each sponsor what kind
of application interview and background
checks does each potential sponsor
undergo
certainly and I'd like to point out that
um at the time that the children are
turned over to Orr from the some cpb
there is documentation that they have
determined is
valid or worth passing on so before a
child enters or our custody there has
been a vetting process and that
continues for the for that is why
children tend to be in RR care for on
average one month with the ongoing
vetting process takes place and it is a
rigorous one it involves relationships
with the country's uh of origin where
primary information is available any
documentation is available from the
sponsors including fingerprinting
licensing license information whatever
um finger checks about against multiple
databases including those for criminal
records or anything of that sort so it
is a rigorous process and it goes on for
at least a month so uh establishing
family relations that are done in
concert with the countries of origin and
original documents are obtained
oh uh despite the fact that there have
been some pretty heartbreaking stories
of sponsors being traffickers or using
the children to work
it's my understanding that this past
fiscal year over 85 percent of sponsors
are close family members is that correct
yes it is and would you say that that
percentage is about on par with what you
saw when you were the director of RR
under the Obama Administration uh it was
very close it may have changed it varies
over time so it a percentage or two
different but roughly the same
and can you share any experiences you
had as directive Orr of reuniting an
unaccompanied minor with their family in
the United States
yes in many instances it is known that
families have been separated for
extended periods of time children have
been traumatized in their home countries
rule of law is limited they've often
been targeted by gangs or violent
elements often as they reach adolescence
so children are being put in the care of
their families which is I believe where
children should be if at all possible
and it has been established then
congregant care facilities are not an
ideal location and are fact harmful for
children so I do think that uh
or are is reuniting families that's the
authority that was given to it by
Congress so the research is rigorous it
is it's it's exhaustive and it's based
on whatever information is available
um but as I said before RR is not an
investigatory audience so there are
limits as to what it can do there are
databases they're fingerprinting there's
our background checks and there are
interviews
thank you based on what we're hearing
today the reality is that the issues
misrotus and the New York Times the flag
should not be happening under current
law and policy I'm very glad that Orr
has announced that it's conducted an
audit of its vetting process Mr Kerry
can you discuss the inherent tension
that exists between trying to ensure the
safety of all these children while also
ensuring the children are not held in
Orr custody for a long period of time
uh yes it is uh it is a delicate process
because children could in theory be kept
in care and different indefinitely but
the goal is ultimately to reunite
children with a caregiver with a parent
with a family member or an individual
who is designated by their parent as the
ideal sponsor so it's important that
children be closely their placement be
closely vetted which it is to the extent
possible but also Paramount that
children can be reunited with a family
member and in a place in a home
environment
thank you I'd like to submit uh Mr
chairman I'd like to submit for the
record uh the testimony of the director
of Orr in front of the house oversight
committee that more than 85 percent of
unaccompanied kids are reunited with
their families without objection thank
you I yield back
yeah now recognizes Mr Roy of Texas
I think the chairman
I would note that
or my child one of the 15 percent
even if I take
the chairman or the ranking member I
should say of his word I would be pretty
frustrated
about your child being lost if you take
your kids to school and they said well
we kept up with 85 percent of them
boy
would you feel good about the education
system
because what about those other 15
percent of kids even if you take
the ranking member at his word
I've got a foia request here from
Judicial Watch from this is now six
years dated
that has a laundry list of incidents put
out by Orr the refuel request
detailing
laundry list of abuses of children
uh this one
young girl reported she was
inappropriately Touched by an unknown
male immigrant in the group after
entering the U.S another one several
appeals reported staff they were uh on
you know inappropriately touched another
one where somebody paid money to have
sex with or another I just go down the
list
of hundreds of these examples
and somehow in the greatest country in
the history of the world the most
powerful country in the history of the
world we think this is a system
that we should defend
it blows my mind that my colleagues and
other side of that I want to defend
a system of laws that allows this to
occur to children and then brush away
that mag extremist New York Times for
daring to point out that 85 000 kids
aren't being
found from the first Contact my
colleagues on the side of the owl say
oh okay we just didn't get him on that
first call
I would act I would ask each of the
witnesses very quickly
do you think that the data is showing
that since President Biden took office
the 356
665 unaccompanied Alien Children
have crossed the southern border that we
know of
and been placed in HHS custody
is a system that attracts that that
number of children unaccompanied
to come across our border to be
exploited by cartels
to be put into the sex trafficking trade
to be put into the slave labor trade to
be sexually abused to die on ranches in
South Texas to drown in the Rio Grande
yes or no is that a system that you're
proud of as an American and that you
think is good no Congressman thank you
ma'am Ms Rodriguez no sir I'm appalled
Miss Vaughn no indeed Mr Carey
it's yes or no question are you proud of
a system in this country that has 356
000 uncommon Alien Children that allow
that to occur to children that we know
by your own acknowledgment and testimony
by our own understanding children are
being abused raped they get killed in
this process the system that we've
created
to allow and attract that flood across
our border
do you think that is a good system and
are you proud of it as an American
these children are fleeing violence and
threats of death in their country the
numbers have been spiking under this
administration because of the policies
of this Administration and it is well
documented I always want to make clear
you're standing behind the policies of
this Administration that you're proud of
these policies
and what that is allowing to occur to
these children
I do not currently work for the
administration I was doesn't matter to
me are you proud of this
administration's policies and what
currently is occurring to these children
because of the policies attracting 356
000 unaccompanied Alien Children when we
know the data 85 000 lost reams of
scores you worked there you know
of the rapes of the people getting
killed of the slave labor
do you think this is a system that we
should say we're proud of
I believe we should provide protection
to children who are fleeing death and
persecution let me ask you a different
question they should be allowed an
opportunity do you believe that the
tbpra policies adopted that unchecked
and unfixed by this current Democratic
uh Administration and by my colleagues
on the other side of the aisle did that
have anything to do with attracting all
of those children across the border well
I do believe that the trafficking
victims protection act is an important
component of U.S Child Protection is it
a magnet right now the weight is
currently constructed why children were
riding on the top of train cars
President Obama was was appalled Jay
Johnson was appalled this Administration
doesn't seem to care yes or no is our
current system a magnet to kids I do not
believe it is you don't believe it's a
magnet no well that's the problem I
yield back
there
thank you
Miss Rodriguez
welcome and thank you for coming today
to testify
Miss Rodriguez were you were you at the
Capitol on January 6th
was I at the Capitol yes I know sir I
was on the premises outside of a
reflection Pond waving a flag so you're
on the capitol crowns
I'm not sure if that's technically
Capital grounds I was near the street
is this your Tweet right behind me at
305 on January 6 2021
I I really do not know
are you at secure border TX yes sir okay
can you see that picture
I I can did you go any farther than
we were in that picture no sir
did you ever cross any police barricades
on January 6th not that I'm aware of
did you ever see any violence on January
6th
no I did not
I did see a red flare go up I don't
remember the time but that was about it
I did not encounter any violence as a
matter of fact it was quite peaceful I
was involved in some prayers day before
so January 6th
over 150 officers were injured one lost
an eye one lost a finger one loss to
life but you didn't see any violence
no sir I did not that was not my
experience
you agree though that violence against
police officers took place that day
sir I'm not quite sure what this has to
do with the exploitation of children
like the young girl who wore this band
sure I guess you know you were called
you publicly tweeted this the majority
knew that you were on the capitol
grounds on January 6th and so you know
your credibility is
just as every witness including the
Democratic witness is Fairgrounds for
questioning and so I guess my question
is
you were aware you are aware that
violence took place at the Capitol on
January 6. that's what the media says
okay okay do you believe the media
apparently I know about January 6th
about January 6th I can only go by my
personal experience and I absolutely if
waving a flag and praying outside of the
Supreme Court and standing outside
waving a flag
um on public property is a crime I I'm
not quite again I'm really not sure what
relevance we have children that are
being raped but others are taxpayer
dollars I'm not quite sure what this has
to do with me waving a flag has to do
with you were among a crowd that did
commit violence and my question for you
is
I accept you at your word you did not
commit any violence that day you didn't
see any violence that day certainly it's
not a lie it's not made up that 150
officers were injured but my question is
to your credibility will you condemn the
violence that took place officers that
day I absolutely condemn any violence
incur including the violence that is
occurring at our Southern border using
our taxpayer dollars absolutely
okay and did you tell the majority
before they invited you here that you
had participated
on the capitol grounds on January 7th
did I tell the majority that I weighed a
flag on did they know that you had
been at the Capitol that was not a
question that I was asked no sir
and
as it relates to January 6 you also
posted a tweet that encouraged people to
attend that day and quote fight for
Trump do you remember writing on January
1 2021 imagine over a million Patriots
screaming fight for Trump
think Congress and the Supreme Court
will hear us when you say fight for
Trump and then there was actually
fighting physical fighting on behalf of
trump what did you mean are you stating
that I tweeted that you don't remember
tweeting no sir I I honestly do not okay
so on January 1 2021 you sent a tweet
that said imagine over a million
Patriots screaming quote fight for Trump
on the sixth think Congress and SC which
I believe a supreme court will hear us
then hashtag fight for Trump your you
your testimonies that you did not say
that I'm saying I do not I honestly do
not remember tweeting that I was not
very active on Twitter well you also
tweeted at four o'clock
I just got home you said I just got
whole safely I think you meant home at
BWI airport is the gate filled up with
those of us with Trump gear on and
several army soldiers near time to
boarding our gate was surrounded by
airport no I will not yield so
you tweeted regularly throughout
the days leading up to January 6th you
asked people to fight for Trump and then
you took a picture of yourself near the
capitol so I just want to know when you
say fight for Trump and people
ultimately fought for Trump do you
regret those words
sir I I do the the second one that you
just read
um yeah because that was a very
traumatic experience I couldn't
understand why my gate surrounding and
in BWI was surrounded by Guardsmen and
how I was we as a whole everyone that
was on that plane were threatened to be
removed I could not understand because
again I did not experience any type of
violence as far as this the first one
that you I would have to go back and
look at that I I really do not honestly
remember tweeting Sherman's time and I
just want to correct I said January 6th
for the BWI Airport it was January 7. I
just wanted
this January 7th was when you tweeted uh
thank you Mr chairman Miss Rodriguez I
apologize that you had to you're here
for a hearing on the board or they don't
want to talk about a border Mr swalwell
is down there obviously everybody knows
he's made some comments he's got a
checkered past he's a legend I'm sorry
I would ask it's my twister alleged
Affairs
you don't get to say that
relationships
I asked the gentleman's words
I am here
let us have some order instability here
and we will take up the issues one by
one Mr chairman I ask that the words of
the gentleman be taken down as a as um
as as expressing a slur on another
member
specific words were
you mentioned that Mr swalwell had a
checkered past I I don't have the rest
of the exact words but it was it was a
direct slur on a member of this
committee that is not acceptable
we're going to consult the Precedence
and take temporary recess thank you
foreign
yes and I would like to rephrase
this is the the same member that was
removed from the intelligence committee
that he previously served on so now
let's get right down to the serious
business as it relates uh to our
Southern border
my question is more related to those who
claim to be minors but pose as the
adults I've got several articles in here
border patrol nabs hundreds of illegal
uh immigrant adults posing as children
border patrol navs uh eight illegal
immigrants who pose as unaccompanied
minors to avoid deportation this is an
article here with our school districts
across the country that are dealing with
this this is from uh City officials in
Lynn Massachusetts that talked about
adults now adults that are in this
country they posed as minors they're in
this country and now we've got 23 24 25
30 year old people in our high schools
think about that they're in our high
schools they're across the entire
country City superintendent of schools
there Catherine Latham in in in Lynn
Massachusetts said this is out of
control they have these individuals are
in their schools there's very little
documentation it says federal policy
prohibits City officials from inquiring
into a child's immigration or citizen
Citizenship status and background we've
got problems here folks we've got
problems and the left is just continuing
to ignore it they're ignoring it Mr
Kerry what proof since we've got
individuals coming in here they're all
what proof is required to determine a
Minor's age
well you talked about screening at the
borders of Customs and Border Protection
I believe are is the law enforcement
entity that determined that these DNA my
friend do they do I think these children
were determined not to be eligible as
minors before they would have been
turned over to Orr so a law enforcement
body determined that they were not
monitors and they did not go into Orr
yeah so so DNA birth certificates
passports medical records what does
somebody need to produce
well in fact birth records and a host of
other materials are collected both from
country of origin and what happens if
they don't have any of these documents
sir
well I believe there are individual
circumstances and those are
in fact what is the protocol then well I
think it would vary greatly I do not
know what it is currently because I'm
not in the
office I this guy here behind me
I'd like to spend a moment with this guy
this guy here 24 years old
he posed as a minor he comes into this
country shares a fake name
not him he wasn't a minor he said he was
16-17 comes in he's 24 years old
or our releases them they send them to
Florida he's over there hanging out with
a fella his sponsor not a father not a
mother just a sponsor and what does he
do
a few short months later he kills him
he kills him
now I don't know what the protocol is
down there but when I look at this guy
he's got more chin whiskers than more 40
year olds have look at that guy
now how does a guy like that get into
this country as a minor
he comes in he says my name is such and
such no such name
and he gets released into this country
and he took a life
there's just more than this guy there
are hundreds if not thousands of them in
this country posing as minors I could
sit here and talk about the MS-13 gangs
that are coming in here and harming our
American people and our citizens and
what are we doing about it
Miss Vaughn I wish I had more time I do
miss Rodriguez ma'am thank you for what
you do thank you for exposing what this
Administration has done to this country
put in the American people last each and
every time
but we're in control now and I can damn
well tell you health is on its way thank
you sir I yield back
um as Ross
thank you Mr chairman earlier this year
I joined several of my colleagues on
this committee to visit McAllen and
Brownsville to Texas border towns while
there we visited an office of refugee
resettlement facility that houses
unaccompanied children
all of these children had families or
sponsors in the United States who were
waiting to take them
we learned that in order to ensure these
kids are treated humanely when they
leave Orr custody Orr conducts an
assessment of the sponsors to determine
that the child is placed in an
appropriate environment
what struck me most about our visit to
the Border was how much our immigration
and Asylum system relies on non-profits
and Community Services in areas like
McAllen and Brownsville
the Biden Administration is working to
scale up post-release services through
which children and their sponsors are
connected to community-based services
with the goal of being able to provide
these services to every child
soon
unfortunately this committee has already
seen too many proposals this year to
strip unaccompanied children of basic
protections
the border security Enforcement Act
would leave kids with a mere cursory
screening by law enforcement Personnel
lacking child welfare expertise who
would be less likely to pick up on signs
of trafficking and exploitation which I
take extremely seriously as a state
legislator I moved through trafficking
bills in North Carolina
it would also result in a summary return
of many kids who fled legitimate dangers
in their home countries
children who arrive at our Southern
border have often escaped violence human
traffickers and gangs in their own
countries
Mr Carey in your opinion
is it better to allow children to remain
in the United States if we can properly
vet the sponsors or to summarily deport
them with limited due process back to a
dangerous situation
thank you for the question uh It is Well
documented that these children are
coming from three of the most violent
countries in the world where there are
extrajudicial killings where children
are recruited or targeted by gangs or
violent elements at the time they reach
adolescence so no I do not think return
without a proper hearing a determination
of their legal access to Asylum is
uh is is determined with ideally legal
representation as uh recommended by the
tdpra and Flores I also think a society
is defined by the way we treat our most
vulnerable and returning and children
are among the most vulnerable so
returning children to a situation in a
country where their lives are at risk
and some have been killed upon return
does not reflect well upon us I do
believe they should have access to a
legal hearing determines the um
the nature that their claim is either
valid or invalid
thank you very much and we did hear from
some of those children adolescents who
had left very dangerous situations Mr
chairman just for a brief period of time
before I reclaim my time I'd like to
yield about 15 seconds to Mr Nadler I I
thank the gentlelady Mr Kerry I just
wanted to ask if I'm correct in that
what you were saying before is that uh
conditions in their home countries are
pushing these people kids and adults out
and it does not matter who the president
of the United States is or what their
policies are these people kids would be
coming because of conditions in their
home countries
it's absolutely and that's very well
documented thank you very much are you
back I thank the general lady Fielding
thank you and just um I completely agree
with all the witnesses that we need to
do more and when we went to border we
saw
just sad sad situations with children
and I want you to know all of you to
know that I am committed to helping and
hopefully in a bipartisan way helping
these children and making sure that they
are safe
um Mr Kerry just in the 10 seconds that
we have have we seen any improvements in
the situation that you think Congress
should invest in further
um absolutely I think post-release
Services which uh would provide legal
representations social workers on an
expanded level which I know Orr is uh is
increasing and would like to have fully
in place within the next two years uh
provides another eye on these children
provides a degree of protection
um that might not otherwise be present
it also
um it
where it's present 90 over 90 percent of
the children show up at their hearings
if there is a problem there are entities
and individuals who can determine that
it exists and refer to social service
providers or law enforcement as
appropriate so I think that is one I do
think that there should be
um there is fortunately a an audit
process going at Orr to determine if
there are what the flaws are and how
those can be approved upon I do think
that clearer lines of authority
and communication between those entities
such as Orr which are in essence social
service providers and law enforcement
and other bodies would be an improvement
on the current program thank you Mr
chair for your Indulgence
uh Mr Moore thank you Mr chairman just a
week ago the New York Times reported
that the Biden Administration has
downplayed repeated signs that migrant
children are being widely exploited I I
would go on record today and say it
doesn't sound like just the bite
Administration based on what I'm hearing
in here but uh Ms Rhodes you mentioned
something and it kind of it it triggered
a response a while ago you said these
kids are being recruited in their home
country what do you mean by that
so
um and I'd be happy to submit for the
record we have children saying that
there are radio advertisements in their
Hometown so in way way tenango for
example in Guatemala they're actually
advertising on the radio come with us
we'll give you passage we'll give you
passage to the United States there's an
example of a sponsor Who currently is in
Austin Texas at this moment he attempted
to sponsor four children one from the
Pomona Fairplex emergency intake site
and three from the Pecos emergency
intake site promising work to these
children who were making two dollars and
fifty cents a day on the coffee farm he
owns in Guatemala so he lured them here
now fortunately they were put into
long-term care but they are being lured
here Facebook ads and other things
children are being lured here and then
put to work here so it doesn't sound
like they're fleeing as much as they're
being baited to come here in a lot of
ways
in many ways they're not fleeing in many
ways I mean let's take El Salvador for
example no one is fleeing from naive
bukeli he's he has a very safe Society
right now yes maybe in times past people
were fleeing El Salvador from The Gangs
but sadly the gangs have now set up
operation here
and we have evidence that there are many
of them who are running the networks
here who have the children it's
indisputable evidence that Department of
Homeland Security has transnational
criminal organizations on The Talk watch
list some of who got their fingerprints
here in Washington DC and neighboring
areas are sponsoring the children it's
indisputable you mentioned too debt
bondage what do you mean when you say
debt bondage and who does the money go
to so the money goes to the trafficker
who ultimately brings them here the New
York Times actually showed I think
Hannah Dreyer did an amazing expose
where she actually showed the debt page
of the child how much the child had to
pay for food how much the child had to
pay for rent all of those things so the
administration is really we're engaged
in creating slavery slavery we are
trafficking slaves to this country
absolutely there is no doubt we have
created a poll and because these this
criminal element
tragically abused children as a
commodity
we they see us as the middleman because
we're paying the flight directly to the
end user the trafficker I remember I was
at Fort Bliss emergency intake Center I
mentioned this last week in a hearing
and I was there as they were shipping
kids on buses all over the country and I
actually asked Admiral run the place I
said are we doing background checks
we're sending these kids to Google
addresses and he's like no we're just
building the bus as we drive it and so
they were just shipping to it on
American taxpayers basically we're
trafficking children yes and making the
cartel wealthy in the process and
creating a bunch of minors in bad bad
situations yeah
going back to 2014 which was astounding
to me because I did not know when I
deployed for this mission that one child
had ever been trafficked through the
program so the horror when someone sent
me the 2016 Senate report I'm sitting
there on the Pomona site seeing all
these strange things and all these
multiple sponsors at multiple addresses
trying to collect these kids from
multiple sites and I read the report and
I thought which side am I on right which
side are you on which side because we
know about trafficking all the way back
then how teens were lured from Guatemala
put in slave labor conditions where they
were held sometimes at gunpoint and
their families were threatened to be
killed so so I've got about 45 seconds
thank you for being a whistleblower I
guess they didn't treat you very nicely
when you blew the whistle out no they
did not they threatened me with
investigation they walked me off the
emergency intake site and they took my
badge my agency thankfully I work for
the Council of the inspectors general
I'm not here in that capacity but they
actually offered to send agents to
retrieve me to escort me home because
they were concerned for my safety it's a
terrible thing when you blow the whistle
and to try to save children and then you
are retaliated against for trying to
help HHS did everything they could to
keep all of this silent let me ask one
more question you said these kids that
they talk about are we sending them to
their moms and their dads you're saying
they have a they hand them a piece of
paper and tell them this is your mom and
this is your dad is that what I gathered
from the testimony well as they're
making their Journey that happens but
then also the case managers who are not
law enforcement right they're not
investigative
they are receiving documents photographs
of documents on their WhatsApp phone and
there's a perfect example a 20 plus year
old man sponsored what we believed was
his sister who was only 16 years old he
submitted a birth certificate for
himself and her as brother and sister
and then about 10 days after she's
released we see she's for sale on on his
um WhatsApp page you know her shirt is
buttoned down to her navel she's all
made up the documents there is no one at
HHS betting the children who is that's
what we need laws I'm out of time Miss
Jeremiah you're back thank you Mr
chairman I have a unanimous consent
request
thank you Mr chairman I would like to
seek unanimous consent to enter into the
record two articles uh one from uh one
from sleep magazine naive bouquet is
Latin America's first Millennial
dictator and another one from CNN while
Salvador's president naive okele wants
everyone to know about his new prison
this one actually talks about how he
went and conducted secret talks with the
MS-13 leaders in prison
and uh
wanted
essentially was looking to release those
gang members just wanted to make it
clear that we're not talking about a
country that has a benevolent government
thank you Mr ladies recognized me
thank you
um in just the first four months of 2023
U.S officials have encountered more than
70 000 unaccompanied children these
children some of them too young to even
fully understand where they are are some
of the most vulnerable people to go
through our immigration system they
desperately need to be shown care and
compassion the same that we should want
for any of the children in our own lives
and instead as we know they are
increasing being put to work in illegal
and unsafe jobs or even worse sent back
into unsafe conditions or human
traffickers we cannot allow this to
happen what do our Republican colleagues
propose we do about this just recently
my colleagues across the aisle passed
out of this committee a bill which guts
existing protections for unaccompanied
children and blocked efforts to allow
government provided lawyers to represent
these children at hearings
simply put they are making an already
complex problem worse and I know every
single Democrat on this side of the
diocese is ready to do all that we can
to improve this effort and ensure that
we have the federal resources devoted to
ensure that no children are forced to
work illegally or in the hands of anyone
they shouldn't be and so I want to ask
you Mr Kerry first
um we all recognize that more has to be
done to protect these vulnerable
children what authorities do you suggest
Congress give it I'd give to help these
children and would government provided
counsel for example be helpful to
protecting Children released to sponsors
what sort of role could an attorney play
and do you think legislation that our
colleagues just passed that bans the
government from providing counsel to
unaccompanied children would result in
more exploitation of children or less
I certainly think it would provide more
exploitation when children are in touch
with internity they are in regular touch
it ensures they show up that their
hearings determining whether they have a
claim whether their lives were in danger
in their country of origin it also is in
an extra party who is seeing the child
who can assess whether they are in
physical danger whether they're going to
school whether they are still living
with their parents or their other
sponsors so yes I do believe that
post-release Services which would also
include access to Social Services and a
host of other physical health services
ensuring that physical needs are being
taken care of educational services and
linkages with other community-based
services for which uh to which children
are legally entitled to access so yes I
believe these would be extremely
beneficial and Mr Kerry in your
testimony you also indicate that HHS
does not have the authority to
investigate what happens to children
after they leave HHS custody what
agencies do have the authority to
investigate those who might put children
in exploitative or dangerous working
conditions or are there so I think
certainly the Department of Labor has
the authority to investigate and enforce
labor law and that would certainly
extend to the exploitation of children
in unsafe working conditions or underage
children working in uh in conditions of
that sort so other law enforcement
bodies I believe as well though I'm not
expert in that area
so
um
what can Congress do to ensure that the
Department of Labor as an example has
what it needs in terms of resources to
go after employers who put children in
any kind of danger
well I co-authored a piece in Slade with
a colleague who's a labor law expert
about a month ago and as she determined
the research that she'd up showed the
Department of Labor is very much
underfunded so the ability to inspect
and enforce labor law is I gather quite
limited so certainly funding to that
body to enable it to investigate and
prosecute would I believe be a critical
factor in reducing the potential for
exploitation of children and finally in
light of that statement you just made um
our colleagues are about to pass a
proposal to deal with the default of the
United States where they are proposing
massive cuts a 22 percent cut in fact on
HHS the Department of Labor the officer
Refugee resettlement so rather than
increases they're going to be very
serious Cuts how would those cuts which
they're going to vote for this afternoon
or tomorrow how would those impact the
catastrophe that we've heard about with
respect to unaccompanied minors
well I believe that the expansion of
post-release services which is underway
and hopefully will be funded would be a
critical element in expanding the
protection of children beyond the point
at which Orr has the authority to do so
so that is moving forward and if that
has expanded in recent years since my
departure but those include Mental
Health Services Social Work support
physical health services educational and
other community-based services I think
all of these enhance the protection of
children beyond the degree the extent
that Orr is able to do so so I think
cutting back those Services I think
inherently increases the threat to
children in society writ large so thank
you are you back Mr chairman and I'll
recognize myself for five minutes first
Rodriguez on behalf of the committee I
apologize for the personal attack that
was hurled to go away in the wild
insinuations
um
has no place in in this committee Ms
Vaughn I want to um
nail down this this question of 85 000
children being simply um
lost by the administration we're told
it's okay they're just not answering
their phones what does it actually mean
to lose track of these children
uh well there
HHS has uh consistently denied that it
has any Authority or responsibility to
the point is they're supposed to be
doing follow-up phone calls correct well
that's that's what these phone calls for
those 85 000 children now simply going
unanswered we don't know where they are
how do we know what has happened to them
we don't and that's the problem and I
don't think we really know what happens
to those who do answer the phone Ms
Rhodes what uh what kind of betting's
actually done to assure somebody
claiming to be a relative actually is
well again DNA test for example as Mr
Kerry mentioned there are no
investigative or law enforcement people
involved in the vetting process in my
experience with what I witnessed at the
Pomona Fairplex emergency intake site
case managers were receiving photographs
of documents
there is no way there was a very small
percentage that we were actually able to
put through the consulate to verify
people are just going off the word who
is Ever sending in the documentation the
vetting process is practically
non-existent they like to talk about a
vetting process but there's no law
enforcement involved in the vetting and
so how can there be a vetting process
and there's lots of talk about the
post-release services post-release
Services 25 of the children who we
released
enforceable we send somebody to visit
these homes before these children are
deposited no absolutely not the the
history is about four to six percent of
homes are ever seen so we're talking
about taking a child I got pet shelters
offer more vetting than that yes exactly
and what kind of follow-up is done well
to assure the the welfare of the child
a phone call that we don't know who's
answered you know who's answered who's
answering the call we cannot verify so
first of all when we do make contact we
don't know if we're actually talking to
the so-called sponsor exactly and for 85
000 of them they're not even answering
they've just completely fallen off the
radar yes chairman yes
Ms Rose has been reported that the
cartels charged thousands of dollars to
traffic these children how are these
debts repaid
how many deaths actually get repaid no
no how are the debts repaid I by working
and sometimes in slave labor there was
an example uh when project Veritas went
and knocked on doors in some of the hot
spots that I gave them a 16 year old
girl said she's being pimped by her
sponsor who claims to be her aunt but
the little girl says I don't know I've
never met her Ms Rodriguez you you have
heard similar stories in Texas is that
correct yeah so that is correct with the
um a lot of the especially the younger
children that I've personally met along
the border again they're they're come
with these small little pieces of paper
with handwritten numbers on them they're
told from what they tell me of who their
sponsors are going to be that this is
there a lot of them as their Theo like
their Uncle their their mother or their
father that they've never met
um and and they don't know who they are
until they've never met them the Florida
grand jury did a five-month study of
this issue in their state and discovered
exactly the same thing so we're seeing
that in California we're seeing it in
Texas we're seeing it in in Florida
um
when we're told these placements are
carefully vetted are are we being
gaslighted
Ms Vaughn
yes and that's why the State of Florida
for example the grand jury there is
recommending that that the state pass a
law requiring these sponsors to come
forward so that the state can do the
vetting because they know that the
federal government is not doing it
um it's simply not happening now if if
these children were safely returned to
their homes what would that do to the
cartels business model
it would dry up that's what that's what
border patrol officers have told me when
I'm down there is is if you get them
safely home they said though they don't
offer refunds a word will spread very
fast that's a bad investment and and the
uh a perilous Journey won't be attempted
and can you give us just a little bit of
insight into that Journey
uh well we know from reports of ngos
that a very large percentage of the kids
who come are abused something like at
least 60 percent of the
um the female migrants are abused
physically often sexually
it's a difficult Journey uh the the
cartels and the Smugglers treat them
like Commodities they don't care about
whether they get enough food shelter
it's terribly traumatic and that's uh
has to be dealt with by the places where
they end up thank you
Miss Jackson Lee
I think the chairman and I thank the
ranking member
and of course acknowledge all the
witnesses there are many of us who have
lived through this in real time
I have been in the Congress since the
number of
legislative
changes and as well the lawsuits that
resulted in the settlement
the floor is settlement agreement
from 1997 in the Homeland Security Act
of 2002 in the William Wilberforce
trafficking victims protection
reauthorization act of 2008.
so we've seen the effort to be
responsible to the children I do want to
set the record straight is that during
the entire four years of the Trump
Administration when they abusively took
children and separated them from
families
it is taken abide Administration to this
time and continuing to try and reunite
those families there was no effort by
the past administration to reunite the
children so I think though it is not
attributable to the witnesses this is a
a Mis statement of this hearing and I
would prefer that we had appropriately
named hearings because I don't think
anyone can document the Biden border
crisis exploitation of unaccompanied
Alien Children I'm not sure if they're
trying to suggest the president is
exploiting them or
innocent workers are trying to exploit
them I'm not sure what that phraseology
means but I think you need to be precise
in what we are speaking of about the
abuse of children I abhor the abuse of
children
I have been at the border and I have
held unaccompanied children
desperately sent because they come from
Desperate circumstances
and the whole question of reuniting or
if they'll safely if they can just
safely return some of these children
leave places that no longer exist family
members are dead they've been taken over
by violence gangs and there's nothing
there
and so I do think it is important that
we stand up a system
that respects cuddles nurtures and
protects these children
so I'm going to start off Mr Carey
discussing the 85 000 lost children
I know that you're not in government now
but you've served it for
and you know that the New York Times
wrote a detailed article with some very
concerning allegations related to
unaccompanied children unlawfully
working in some very dangerous
conditions the article also talked about
how the office of refugee resentment did
not know the whereabouts of about 85 000
unaccompanied children will be released
to sponsor since the Bible
Administration began many outlets and
some of my colleagues have latched on to
this headline to say the buying
Administration has lost 85 000 children
let's start with the most important
question but I do want to say this
you're in the Obama Administration
we have been children have been
unaccompanied
we saw a processes being utilized
not perfect because in trying to settle
children I know for sure being at sites
where you wanted to make sure that
children were going to loving relatives
or someone that was going to care for
them
in the course of
securing sponsors upon sponsors showing
up and some of these sponsors were the
ones that were on the little notes that
the children had with a phone number
so those who are dealing with these
children were only trying to get them
where they need to be again I reiterate
the fact that the children under Trump
were snatched away
from their families purposely to
discourage them from coming can you
explain why they're not in fact lost and
my time is short so I'm just gonna and
did this same issue also occur during
the previous administration would you
would you answer that please oh yes
thank you
um I would pretend that you know every
uh child
receives a call a follow-up call
many do not answer so uh not answering a
phone call I'm particularly if you're
with your parents I do not believe
constitutes being lost and in many cases
they are known to other bodies
um to the legal system which they're
going through to hear their claim to
determine if they have a
you know if they are as they're going
through the legal process whether they
have an asylum claim so you know they
could be in school they could be under
under teenagers children many other
entities May well be aware of their
location but especially their parents to
whom they've been released
generally these times expired
and give us the chairman
um
I actually went to the Border many times
and lost Congress and recently dead and
um it's unfortunate that it's not
bipartisan issue because you know I'm a
mother of two teenage girls and if I
would do what done to some of these
children I would be in jail for child
neglect and these kids deserves the same
level of protection as everyone else and
we're creating perverse incentives and
unfortunately I think the pendulum has
swung too far with this administration
because they really wanted to quickly
push kids out of care that they don't
have overwhelmed shelters versus
worrying about safety because when I was
when several years ago to Texas to some
of the shelters and I think people who
worked there was very disturbed that
proper background checks were not used
and covet was the use as a pretense to
do that and I don't know Mr orders if
you if you're aware or not or any of you
that didn't stop because we don't have
covet pandemic now is it still the
background check I mean it was an
inexcusable to use covet and not really
to worry about safety of the shooter but
you know if there's guidance and this
field guidance is still in place so now
they're doing better checks are you
aware any of you
thank you congresswoman to my knowledge
all of the field guidance that was put
in place is still in place which means
that background checks for household
members are no longer required so in
instances where a person is sponsoring
and there's five other adult males in
the room or in the dwelling none of them
need to go through any type of
background check at all so it is a
system that is easily abused because
there are situations where when
reporters go knocking on the doors
they're finding a child unrelated female
on male as well living with five or six
adults to whom they are not related yeah
and it's unfortunate because now we have
traumatized kids there's massive debts
to cartel and I guess you know cartels
don't do that but some very creative
attorneys do so no one really dealing
with that issue you have a situation in
Indiana actually the judges are shocked
to see what's happening in some meat
packing plans with child play and I
think no one even realized until you
know these kids had some violations that
they had to go to court system and it is
becoming a huge huge problem and I think
that shouldn't be a partisan issue we
created child slavery here in this
country we talked about China having
slaves what are we doing in the United
States of America with government money
that's unexcusable and it is a
humanitarian crisis in addition to
security crisis you know and I you know
I also wanted to see how you know as I
understand they have this post-release
services but I hear from some people on
the ground that actually sponsor can
deny the services is that correct have
you heard that though yes yes
Congressman that's absolutely correct
and that actually is what contributed to
the Marion Ohio situation is that a call
was made and then the case was just
simply closed so today post-release
Services is absolutely not enforceable
and it would also mean that you have a
case manager who trained enough to know
to even activate the post-release
services so just because there's
post-release Services it's it's not
required it is not mandatory and the
sponsor can say thank you very much do
not call me again bye because there is
no Authority that HHS has or office of
refugee resettlement has to hold the
sponsor accountable and this is what's
most baffling
it is a simple fix the sponsor needs to
be held accountable why is this a
difficult thing I do not understand
it's the simple simple fix sponsors are
accountable sponsors are accountable to
put the children in school the sponsor
should be accountable to take the child
to the immigration hearing that is what
the sponsor signs up for but that is not
what the sponsor is held accountable for
and there's no legal mechanism to make
them accountable and if that changed
then children would not be trafficked
well I appreciate for doing them here
and then Mr chairman I hopefully we will
actually be able to as the discussion
the the discussions from the
administration Ori and HSS has to
respond to us because this is inhumane
this is irresponsible and it only
benefits cartels it making a lot of
money on Desperate people that come from
very poor conditions and American
government shouldn't be subsidized and
otherwise we're Hypocrites when we
criticize other country for doing things
like that I think this should not be a
part is an issue I appreciate you being
here today and I hope we can actually
find solutions to stand with these
children and stop this incentivizes this
anxiety on the border for National
Security so thank you back thank you Ms
Escobar
well I'd like to thank the witnesses for
being here today and I'd like to express
my
[Music]
um
frustration I I wish this were a real
hearing that would result in real
solutions and real improvements that
would benefit children but unfortunately
this is not a serious hearing this is a
hearing that's intended to completely
distort the record
and really it's it's strictly for
political purposes but I do agree with
my colleague
from the gentlelady from Indiana we do
need bipartisan Solutions and we do need
a bipartisan effort if we are going to
truly address this so what would that
look like and and I think first I'd like
to preface my comments by sharing with
you all I represent El Paso Texas Fort
Bliss which is in El Paso is home to one
of the largest emergency intake
facilities I have spent a lot of time at
the emergency intake facilities I have
spent a lot of time talking to children
I am bilingual so I speak to the kids in
their native language I have spoken to
innumerable staff former current
staff and I myself have pushed on the
administration at times when I've had to
but what I have found is unfortunately
here in the House of Representatives
there is an absolute unwillingness by my
Republican colleagues to participate in
real solutions
so what would some of those Solutions
look like number one legal Pathways true
legal Pathways for children to reunify
them with their family members would
absolutely circumvent a horrific Journey
that many of them take but we can't get
them to work with us on more legal
pathways
another solution investing in programs
to make sure that there is robust
support we can't get that either in fact
the the president's budget the uh the
the amount of funding that he requested
was actually ratcheted down by
Republican colleagues and then when we
had the Omnibus vote the vote for the
budget that would fund HHS and the
Department of Homeland Security and a
number of other agencies
the chairman voted against it last
December so when you starve a system and
you do everything possible to create
legal Pathways you're not serious about
solving these issues and in fact when
you call for the reinstatement of
horrific policies by the previous
administration including deliberate
family separation you're not interested
in solutions that help kids and last
week when we were here trying to create
protections for children so that they
could have access to legal counsel or so
that they would not be deported even
infants by themselves my Republican
colleagues all voted against those
protections so let's not pretend this is
a serious hearing wanting to truly help
children there is nothing further from
that fact Mr chairman I'd like to enter
into the record a fact sheet by HHS the
registration for Children and Families
one of the witnesses claimed that there
is no home study the fact she disputes
that and the facts are that Orr requires
a home study for children who are 12
years and under before unification with
a non-relative sponsor may I have
unanimous consent attention to the
record
um when I every time I visited the
emergency intake facility at Fort Bliss
and I spoke to kids their complaint was
that the background system was taking
too long and that they were not being
reunited quickly enough with their
families because it was so stringent Mr
Kerry in the remaining 40 seconds is
there any other misinformation that
you'd like to clarify
yes I think it's important to recognize
that the
or vetting system is rigorous any system
is imperfect but it is balancing the
need of children to be reunited with
their families with their mothers with
their fathers versus staying in care and
the resources to do so I believe should
be increased and I believe there should
be more interagency cooperation and
clear lines of authority and Leadership
such that the lines of communication
between Orr and other entities that are
coming in touch with these children are
perhaps improved thank you for those
real solutions that's what we should
focus on and it should be bipartisan I
yield back thank you I saying no other
members seeking recognition that
concludes today's hearing I want to
thank our Witnesses for appearing before
the subcommittee today without objection
all members will have five legislative
days to submit additional written
questions to the witnesses or additional
materials for the record and without
objection the hearing is adjourned
behind me
foreign
thank you